[Music]
in human-hybrid news o submitted by
george jetson an Oxford professor claims
that aliens are already breeding with
humans on earth like illegal aliens or
like extraterrestrials he's still an
Oxford professor in Oxford
did you know that University is older
than I think the Aztec empire
dude I was watching this documentary on
disinformation have you seen that on
Netflix it was a Swedish show it was
about disinformation so people are hired
in the government and this was
specifically in relations to aliens no
and it's a documentary for watching
but the this guy they interview this guy
that was hired as a disinformation
specialist and basically anyone that
would claim to see UFOs or have alien
experiences he would go out there and
like talk to them and like we have a
little stick no word he'd validate them
and then give them extra information
that's not true and he mixed it in with
real information just yes and so then
they could even crazier like this just
happening and I heard it from the
government and all this stuff and so
then they look crazy and everyone dis
credits them so his whole job was to
like discredit everyone that believed in
aliens or anyone that was spreading him
any information at all to you know his
whole job was to spread disinformation
and so he retired and he likes he
dressed and all that I don't know he
would go to all the events all the like
like little cons that they had it like
they look like they have alien cons or
whatever and he would like spread
disinformation but yeah he's retired now
and that's why he's a lot to talk about
it but then at the end so he talks about
stuff that he's seen like documents
about aliens and like that they've bred
with humans but then you don't know is
that disinformation you don't know this
guy's whole job is like to create this
information patrol yeah it could be well
what kind of professor is he because it
feels like a journalism professor this
guy or like an English professor so his
name I'll just women study yeah women
study you know all that [ __ ] liberal
arts that's [ __ ]
so his name is dr. young hey chief a
Korean guy he's an instructor in Korean
at Oxford's Oriental instant
okay so he's just a language professor
no cuz I was thinking that something
related to space yeah well they say a
Spacey professor at the British in space
is what's his major Korean Jew Jesus
it just says an instructor in Korean
what creep that windows in the oriental
department yeah he's a hunger guy yeah
that's what I was hoping that it was
like a science professor someone that's
like instead of you I coalesced yeah and
on my odo he's just a dude that wears
kimonos every day but he probably
watches ancient aliens so he's got it's
a humble cubase to have oh good I
thought you were trying to make a joke
because I'm like oh cause he's in a
different country and they're like it's
my races yeah that's what I thought you
because it's called oriental I thought
you were making a joke
Korean kimono handbook just for women
it's both men when I'll be quite when is
when now you're making me second-guess
myself but guys how guys have what I got
it girls that way yep why just need the
girl won't was a humbug but I didn't
know the guy was off you although it's
both it's both okay yeah listen to him
Korean traditional wear looks so soft
and SIL
it looks not saw first of all the only
thing is like 30 pounds yes shiny issues
there summer dress
I have already 30 layers and they're
winter one has like 80 layers
Oh Chinese looks often like that looks
soft that's some silky ass [ __ ] dude
Gina cracked me the [ __ ] up because on
Twitter there was this girl who was she
was twerking a [ __ ] in the Chinese dress
and then some you know one go don't
sexualize my culture bottle and that
generally those have you seen the
enemies cafe girls half naked like what
do you talk to you about I think oh
that's true we kind of do it ourselves
you know so this guy thinks that
Damien's been [ __ ] our peoples yes he
says that there are you might be right
because Asians look like aliens and
that's what all of the abductees say
that happens to them they say like it
probe after they like Scott
that the people that are claiming the
abductions that rate is going up just
like equally as climate change so he's
saying that it correlates mmm that these
bug like aliens are causing climate
change no that they're creating a new
hybrid species that could one day save
Earth from climate change and other
disasters and they're trying to create
these these hybrids because they expect
these new new hybrids to survive the
well maybe the the alien spaceships are
creating the climate change is it's all
hot the survival of the entire bias
that's very positive with him
yeah he's saying that big quote they
come not for the sake of us but for the
sake of them their survival there but
their survival is actually our survival
as wealth the survival of the entire
biosphere I mean if they're so damn at
bats I don't understand why they they
don't just play daddy and they show and
they show up until I Hey
you guys are [ __ ] dumb you're ruining
the work world you need to be slaves
maybe they did do that to the
governments of our countries but they're
not doing nothing maybe they're secretly
doing things oh maybe they did that in
the past I want more electric cars and
hybrids yeah cuz that's not happening
he's saying that four types of aliens
that they're small tall and bold the
only official names aliens with skills
and small or grande this one's tall
insect-like and they're saying that the
insect like one ranked highest in the
totem pole maybe get sick they've
probably boss the other ones around
there like big cockroach looking I don't
know how big there's no pictures other
interviews of the other professors on
what they think about this guy I can I
want to see the other nobody looks like
characters that's Park you look like a
conspiracy theorist you know there's
these Dan that's well but it's also a
while to be like should you discredit
this guy yeah because he's a language
professor yeah exactly
he might know
setting black holes first and then he
could say this yeah but I don't know if
all departments are taught so he's
saying that he has three theories either
they find human DNA valuable for
preserving their species they want to
create a species that can survive future
climate calamities or they are trying to
produce an intelligent future leader so
if you guys are into aliens and
conspiracies the things that he's
talking about it's not things that he
came up with things
they're already out there and he's just
studying that and talking about it yeah
so like the four races of aliens and all
that stuff and the different reasons why
they might be here and and all that that
is something that already exists and
it's not something that he's breaking
through and saying like I found this
[ __ ] yeah he's also saying that he
doesn't think that these aliens are far
away that they're just right next to us
but we can't see them because our human
perception is limited by our organs and
it's unclear if humans would even
realize that he or she had encountered a
how come he likes he's merging the men
in black movies with some of these
conspiracies and how come like these a
like he's [ __ ] us in the ass
like what's with that the whole anal
probing thing what's the purpose of this
they can collect bio whatever feel like
you know when you collect samples dirt
talk to do black holes I like black
holes so I'm going to your black hole
that's true thank you just go into our
sewer system and collect a lot of data
yeah or if they're so advanced why do
they always have to go up the stinkiest
place maybe they know something was up
there that's special Mather and we were
brainwashed to think it's nest yeah no
we smell it yeah it smells like poop
wash yeah program to smell that and then
I think it's bad for them wanting to
[ __ ] us is kind of weird because like
when if I if I'm an alien right and I go
to like planet Dawg I'm not gonna want
to [ __ ] that maybe they [ __ ] differently
maybe they don't [ __ ] missionary like
the Coneheads remember the Coneheads
they put the [ __ ] rings at end they
[ __ ] like that they rub their heads or
something they like to chew on condoms
yeah I love and they don't have a
butthole they have like these two little
things in their back they [ __ ] Eskimo
kiss all day yeah there's just so many
like weird unsolved stuff here like you
know just like even the pyramids thing
like I still don't understand that [ __ ]
like Hobby move those gajillion
ton stones in it doesn't make [ __ ]
sense I want somebody to figure that
[ __ ] out did you know that while they
were when they had the pyramids the
woolly mammoth still existed that's oh
and somehow if humans did that they had
the technology can't even figure out now
how do how to move a [ __ ] gajillion
ton stone and then build it up but
somehow they did it dude we were
listening to this podcast with this guy
named Graham something yeah don't put me
on Graham Norton or something yeah and
he was the comedian no he's like an
archaeologist or an anthropologist yeah
and they were talking he was talking
about like the ancient Greeks already
had like a form of a [ __ ] computer
like built it was a navigational device
yeah they found underwater and it's
basically helping you align the Stars
and all this that it can compute like
based off of the Stars and longitude and
latitude ins that's amazing and there's
Polynesia and DNA in some tribes in the
Amazon but basically his whole whole
talk is about there's just being called
the the Clovis event right and it's a
time in history when when the belief is
in archaeology that we all came like we
as in like humans came over the Bering
Strait and in Native Americans are
descendants of that but his theory is
that the know there's like been multiple
migrations to the Americas and in the
the natives and Americas are a kind of
like a melting pot of the the what do
you call it the migration over the years
and it's older than what we think it is
past the Ice Age of when the Bering
Strait had you know a landmass where
people could walk yeah and then I guess
his whole thing is that in archaeology
like they they don't treat it as science
it seems like because in science you're
supposed to be able to kind of dispute
this fact and whatever but it's so
dogmatic that if you come out and talk
about anything that goes against that
theory of the Clovis theory then you're
looked upon as like some crackpot other
than that like yeah but what they found
is uh so like you know those Aboriginal
tribes like the Australian ones like
Papua New Guinea or the ones in New
Zealand the one in Australia they live
in their tribe
untouched from modern influence so they
haven't evolved for thousands of year
that's exactly who they are so their DNA
it's like extremely pure and they found
the in the Amazon when they found bones
they found the exact DNA match all the
way in the Australian tribes oh that's
what they're saying this is like this is
this completely negates the Bering
Strait migration it's an exact DNA match
to them so he's thinking and some sort
of Ice Age there was another migration
that came either over the Pacific Ocean
or something like that it's crazy yeah
it's pretty dope you should watch him
that's cool I think his book is called
fingerprints of the gods and then
there's another one that came out after
that that he's promoting
[Music]